the government has assured that foreigners
in France were always welcome
their life may nevertheless be complicated we will stop there with you
Amara la cool hello
thank you for being with us
you are editor in chief of the site info migrant point net here at France 24
first what will change for asylum seekers
yes,
this law also concerns asylum seekers and what changes
it concerns especially the CND
the cnda is the national court
of asylum is where asylum seekers go
that the offer failed uh 1 1st time so the offer is the refugee office
stateless persons
he is the only one with the authority to review the applications
1 time you are disgusted at the brake
this decision can be appealed to the CND a
and that's pretty important because when
25% of cases drafted by the CND a
so uh there may be misses at love Prat
sometimes for language or other reasons
until now in fact there were 3 judges who could hear uh
the le débouter of which 1 appointed by the HC R
uh on these 3 judges and there the reform in fact is the only judge
there are no more than 3 judges there is no more collegiality
there is only one single judge who can uh
hear and so uh applicants for asylum
it does not have the possibility
to convince only one person and then there is more debate
so many associations in fact
say it's 1 hindrance
1 infringement of the rights of applicants
and since there is no longer any debate
more possibility of
to discuss this case
so the decision is weaker and
as an example and to show how problematic it can be
so already at the end of November uh
the judges of the SNCF were in danger in part because of this measure
and then at the end of October there was 1 SNCF judge who was dismissed
because of taking a position uh
uh homophobic and uh islamophobic on social networks
so uh,
it shows that it is problematic to reduce
that to this decision which is nevertheless
crucial for the future of the person uh to 1 person
change also Amara around family yes
then there are several restrictions
so for example until now in fact we could uh hum
when you are a regular foreigner to bring in uh
someone in his family after 18 months in France
are justified by correct resources
there we will already have to wait 24 months
and then on the justification of the resources we add criteria
there are 1 1 criteria of regularity
so in fact when we talk about regularity we
there are not many details that are given
but we think that maybe
a declared salary must be justified
and above all perhaps a long-term contract
which is not always the case and not always easy
to obtain when you are a foreigner
then 1 new criterion also which is eliminated
which is 1 French language criterion is enshrined in the law
that a person who requests to enter French territory
as a family
must be able to justify by any means
that she learned from the rudiments of the French language
to her from uh
what is written is that she must be able to express herself in an authentic way
so there we take 1 example without speaking Elisabeth born
here you go
so we
we take the example of a father who would be in France
who would like his wife and children to come
this wife her children in any case at least the wife uh
or if it was his parents must
to be able to justify that they can speak French 1 minimum
here it is not sure it passes to the constitutional council
3rd point Amara
helps the benefits that have crystallized uh
tensions between the right and the presidential majority
the conditions of grant there are yes
and this is the most problematic point
and which could be retouched by the constitutional council
we have talked a lot about housing assistance
for which now it will be necessary for all the aids
regular foreigners
outside the European Union will have to justify 5 years of stay
so this is for all help
unless we work
if the regular foreigner works for the APL he will have to justify 3 months
but it's not just the APL
there are also family allowances and therefore for other aids than the APL
it will be necessary to justify 30 months
and therefore when we say justify it will be necessary
that he justifies the contribution
that one who contributes on a salary-paid job
so this means that we are talking about a job
declared or it is known that many regular aliens of regular immigrants
there are many who work uh
sometimes because they have difficulty finding a job
or for uh any other reason so let's imagine 1 family of 2 parents
3 children who are in school
who are regular who have papers
let's imagine that in fact they both work with his parents
well,
they won't be able to get anything for 2 and a half years of work
and this is when the person has found this declared job
that's it for these upheavals thank you very much